بناءً على طلب
شركائنا الدوليين ، نعمل مع
القوة هناك على الأرض في أفغانستان
لاستئناف العمليات في المطار
بحيث يمكن للرحلات المغادرة
وكذلك الرحلات الداخلية استئناف
العمليات العادية
كما يمكنك أن تتخيل بعد ذلك.
لقد غادر العديد من الخبراء البلاد
وبعد أن كان المشغلون والعديد منهم
شركات أجنبية بشكل أساسي
وفر الخبراء من البلاد ، ولم يتبق
سوى القليل جدًا من الخبرة
لإدارة المطار ، وهذا جانب واحد منه
والجانب الآخر هو في الواقع الفعلي
البنية التحتية يبدو أن العديد من
المعدات تالفة أو تم
الاستيلاء عليها بالفعل وبالطبع هناك لعبة إلقاء اللوم
هناك بين مختلف
أه على الأرض الذين لم يفعلوا
هذا أو أن
دورنا هنا
فريقنا الفني هناك أساسًا
لتسهيل  العمل مع
الشركاء الدوليين لاستئناف العمليات في
المطار ولذا الوزير هل تعلم في هذه
المرحلة ما إذا كانت قطر جيدة  د - توفير
الأمن أه وتشغيل المطار
، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك
، فإلى متى لا يكون الأمن جيدًا ، ويظل هذا موضوعًا محل نقاش
يبدو أن
طالبان تصر على الجانب الأمني ، لك
ما لا يدركون أنه ال
من في مطار يختلف كثيرًا عن
تأ
الجانب الخارجي أو المحيط من
المطار حتى لا يدركوا أشياء
مثل القياسات الحيوية وجميع التدابير
التي يجب أن يتخذها أي مطار
دولي من أجل العمل ،
لذلك نحاول التفاوض على هذا
لشرح مدى تعقيد العملية
ولكن  الأمن بالتأكيد
عنصر لن
أه يكون معنا في قطر ونحن
نناقش هذا الأمر مع طالبان
والشركاء الدوليين من جانبنا سيكون
المساعدة الفنية وكذلك
المساعدة في نهاية المطاف بالطائرات
وكذلك هل تقلق أنا أعرفك  نتحدث
عن الانخراط البناء
اهمية بناء تفاعل
مع طالبان في مرحلة الوزير
لكن هل تقلق هل انت قبل كل
شيء صحيح؟  لطالبان ووعودهم
التي
قطعوها وأنتم تقلقون بصراحة من أن ذلك قد يأتي
بنتائج عكسية
، فلدينا مخاوفنا
ومخاوفنا ولا شك في أن هذا
يجب أن يكون عملية بناء ثقة
اتفقنا جميعًا مع شركائنا الدوليين
على التسرع في الاعتراف
ليس بالضرورة القرار الأكثر حكمة
لاتخاذ الآن ، لكن الحوار البناء
مهم للغاية ، لذا سيكون عملية
بناء ثقة
، من المهم جدًا أن
نبني جميعًا
ونستفيد من البراغماتية التي
أظهرتها طالبان حتى الآن في حاجة طالبان
للمجتمع الدولي  إنهم يدركون
هذا ويقولون هذا ولهذا السبب
نحتاج إلى الاستفادة من هذه اللحظة ، فإن
إغلاقهم تمامًا
لن يكون مفيدًا جدًا في هذا
الموقف ولهذا السبب نحتاج إلى التفكير في
طرق أخرى للتعامل معهم دون
تقويض حقوق الإنسان دون
تقويض  حقوق المرأة دون
تقويض جميع المعايير الدولية
التي نتبناها جميعًا بشكل جماعي
و  نعتقد أن هناك فرصة حقيقية
هنا لتبرير
أفعالهم العامة
الآن ، وقد يستغرق تغيير أيديولوجيتهم
سنوات وعقودًا إذا كان
سيحدث تمامًا ، ولكن
يجب أن يكون ترشيد تصرفاتهم العامة
هدفنا الواضح والعملي للغاية ، ولا
نهتم ويجب علينا  لا يهتمون
بأفعالهم الخاصة داخل مجالاتهم الخاصة ،
ما يجب أن يكون مهمًا هو المجال العام ،
ما يجب أن يكون مهمًا هو
تصرفاتهم العامة ، ما يجب أن يكون مهمًا هو
الصالح والمصالح الجماعية
لشعب أفغانستان في نهاية
اليوم وسأختتم  مع هذه
النقطة في نهاية اليوم ،
لا ينبغي أن نركز فقط على النخبة في
المجتمع الأفغاني ، يجب أن ننظر
إلى المناطق الريفية في المجتمع الأوسع ، المقاطعات الأخرى ،
سيعاني هؤلاء الأشخاص
اقتصاديًا في النهاية ما لم
ننتقل إلى المجتمع الدولي
ونساعد  وهذا للأسف لا يمكن أن
يحدث دون التعامل مع جميع الأطراف
على الأرض ونحن نضغط من
أجل الشمول  الحكومة مع طالبان أه
في مناقشاتنا السابقة وما زلنا حتى
هذه اللحظة نضغط من أجل
المزيد من مشاركة النساء كنا
نضغط من أجل تعليم المرأة في
نهاية اليوم أعني أن هناك العديد من
الدول الإسلامية التي تشارك في
مناقشات مع  بما في ذلك
قطر ولدينا تعليم نسائي ،
لدينا نساء يشاركن في
القوى العاملة أكثر من 50 في المائة من قوتنا
العاملة من النساء ، كل هذه النقاط
التي نحاول دفعها في مناقشاتنا مع
طالبان مرة أخرى أريد التأكيد على
ما يهم هو تصرفاتهم العامة و
لقد أظهروا قدرًا كبيرًا من البراغماتية
التي يجب علينا كمجتمع دولي
الاستفادة منها